le deuxième risque il est plus souvent
discuté c'est celui de la désinformation
bien sûr ça vous avez déjà dû réflécher
dessus entend de parler
beaucoup je suis un peu moins inquiet
dans la mesure où certes là je pense
qu'on ouvre une période de peut-être 2 3
ans où beaucoup de gens vont se faire
avoir parce que ils vont soit voir des
photos des vidéos en croyant que ce sont
des preuves de véritable événement alors
qu'en fait ça aura été généré par Ia
bien sûr dans le cadre de campagne
électorale tout le monde voit ce que ça
peut donner ou bien parce que il y aura
des campagnes de désinformation qui
seront mené avec des génération de
textte très spécifiquement ciblé sur ce
qui vous intéresse ce qui vous touche ce
qui vous ce qui vous ce qui vous
scandalise donc ça c'est très clair mais
à la limite ça ça fait que que prolonger
encore une fois un mouvement qu'on voit
déjà le le le Web ne manque pas de faux
contenus et d'images mensongères et de
des informations déjà aujourd'hui donc
on avait pas vraiment une pénurie de
fausse information et vous savez le
chercheur enfin le chef de la recherche
en nia de méta Yann Lequin dit justement
que le problème de la désinformation
c'est plutôt une question de
distribution euh de l'information donc
c'est celle des réseaux sociaux plus que
de la génération donc à la limite lia ne
fait que amplifier un petit peu un
phénomène qui en fait est déjà très
présent en revanche je pense que dans 2
3 ans euh ce sera devenu un donné enfin
une sorte de position de principe que
une image qu'on voit quelque part sur
Internet aura probablement été générée
par uneiaa parce que bientôt les la
plupart des plateformes de réseaux
sociaux proposeront de générer soi-même
des photos je sais pas sur Instagram
vous pourrez appuyer sur un bouton et
avoir des photos de vous à la plage qui
ne sont pas vrais et vous saurez que
c'est pas vrai et donc quand tout le
monde a cette idée quand tout le monde
sait que une photo a plus de chance
d'avoir été générée par uneia que d'être
que de refléter la réalité je pense que
les gens feront moins seront moins
sensibles à au piège de la de la
désinformation en revanche
l'inconvénient c'est que ça va jeter le
doute sur les vraies photos sur les
vraies informations tout deviendra en
fait sujet à à remise en question c'est
déjà le cas certes à cause de la
retouche de photo qui est possible
depuis l'invention du dagerotype mais là
ce sera tellement plus facile que on
aura une sorte de défiance de principe
qui a d'autres inconvéniant peut-être
que les gens se feront donc moins avoir
par la désinformation mais en fait ils
seront aussi plus sceptiques de la
véritable information et je suis pas sûr
que ce soit tellement mieux en réalité
ça ça montre à quel point le travail de
confiance sur les institutions au sens
large sera important parce qu'en fait on
revient justement au monde d'avant la
photographie on a eu une période en fait
une sorte de parenthèse un peu heureuse
où entre l'invenion de la photographie
et celle de l'age générative d'image
en principe on avait un moyen qui dans
90 % des cas permettait de dire que la
représentation qu'on avait d'un
événement était une preuve de vérité on
voyait une vidéo c'était probablement
que c'était
vrai c'était en fait un moment assez
unique dans l'histoire humaine qu'on
avait pas avant évidemment si on vous
montre une gravure ou une peinture ça
prouve rien enfin et là on revient à ça
on montre une photo une vidéo mais ça
prouve rien en fait et donc là on va
devoir revenir à ces en fait aux
relations de confiance qui devait être
créé auparavant faire confiance à telle
institution tel journal à tel agence de
presse à tel gouvernement évidemment à T
administration